[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHET HAASE: Good morning.
And welcome to Android
for Java Developers.
This talk is a wrap around a
series of very long articles
that I hope everyone
will read eventually,
called Developing for Android.
So if you go to medium.com
and search for that phrase,
or if you just go to
the internet and search
for that phrase, you'll wind up
on the series of 10 articles.
These came out of an
incredibly long doc
that we wrote
internally at Google,
when we were faced with
a bunch of app developers
we would meet with
on a regular basis.
And someone said, so every time
we talk to the framework team,
and we say we're
doing this thing,
and then the framework
team says, no, no, no,
don't do it that way, do
it this other way instead--
and then they'd go away
and they'd do that.
And they'd come back
with another question.
And we would say, no, no,
no, you shouldn't do that.
What you should actually do
is this other thing instead.
And they said, OK, so where do
we go for the information that
sort of collects all these tips,
and tricks, and techniques, so
that we can stop getting
slapped by the platform
team for the way that we're
approaching this stuff?
So that was the
genesis of the article.
We decided to actually take
a step back and say, OK,
what are all the things
that we think are obvious,
but typical Java
developers do not?
And the problem is that a lot
of developers, most developers,
writing Java code at Google come
from the server world, or even
the desktop world, sort of
traditional Java platform.
And then they say, OK, well,
this is the same language,
so I'll carry over all
my patterns and practices
from that other world into
this little, tiny mobile device
with a constrained CPU, GPU,
memory, the limited memory,
limited bandwidth, like very,
very different programming
environment.
Really, the only
thing that is the same
is the programming
language itself.
So the way that you use
that programming language
is very important, in
terms of the performance
and the experience
that you're going
to get in the end result
of your application.
So we wrote this huge article.
We put it out internally.
And then for the short
attention span public,
we broke it into 10 still
very long articles on Medium.
So please check those out.
In the meantime,
I wanted to walk
through some of those today.
If I tried to go
through everything,
this would be about
a three-hour talk.
We tried this once.
We gave a talk at a user
group in the Bay Area,
and we put together a
version of this talk.
And we made it about
a quarter of the way
through in an hour
and 20 minutes.
So yeah, actually, three hours
is an underestimate as well.
Because each of the topics, like
they're little, tiny bullets,
but they're kind
of deep crevices
that you can go on
at length about.
So I thought, instead
today, instead
of trying and failing
to cover everything
that those articles cover, I
wanted to talk about the memory
situation, because a
lot of the performance
concerns and a lot of the
problems that people hit
are in the specific
area of memory.
That's really where a lot
of the performance problems
and bottlenecks
come from, partly
because the runtime and
the garbage collector
are vastly different than
what you might expect.
So I wanted to start
out first by talking
a little bit about how garbage
collection and allocation
actually works on Android.
And then we'll talk about
some of the tips and tricks
about memory in particular.
And then maybe we'll talk
about some other stuff as well.
We'll see how far we get.
So first of all, I
wanted to mention
that one of the important things
that we see in terms of device
usefulness or application
niceness is what we call,
the Tragedy of the Commons.
And this is an effect
where every application
will work in its best interest.
It will be necessarily greedy.
Because obviously, if
someone has installed
my video-playing
application, it's
really important to
them for the user
to actually watch the
videos in my application,
so I'm going to
sync all the time.
And I'm going to make sure they
get the most up-to-date data.
And I'm going to allocate
tons and tons of memory
so that I have all
the stuff cached
and it's just ready
to go all the time.
The fact is, the user has many,
many applications installed.
Yours is one of them.
And if it's too
greedy, yours will not
be one of them for long, right?
If every application
act in this way,
and they do tend
to by default, then
it makes the overall device
experience suck, right?
If every application is
allocating too much memory,
if it takes up too much heap,
if every process is huge,
then the task manager
will continually
be killing all of the
background applications
in order to make the
foreground application
have enough memory
to run itself.
And then, when your rather
greedy and bloated application
goes into the background,
and the task manager says,
well, I'm running out
of memory, I'd better
go look for some
large memory users,
it's going to find yours,
and it's going to kill it.
And the next time the
user goes back to it,
it's going to have to
relaunch and do a cold start,
because it was killed, right?
Wouldn't it be nicer if
all the applications were
more slim and trim, so that
whenever the user switches
between them, they can do
so easily, because they just
have to page them in,
instead of actually
reloading and relaunching
everything from storage?
So there's two
effects that we see.
There's the tragedy
of the commons where
everything is greedy,
and then there's
the every device a village.
So not only are all the
applications greedy,
and they are suffering for it,
but then the overall device
is suffering for it.
Now, the user experience from
all these greedy applications
on the device is that
they're constantly
relaunching all of
the activities there,
or some service running
in the background
is syncing, causing
performance problems
and the CPU to be doing things
for absolutely no reason
whatsoever.
I'm not using that
service right now.
I haven't used that
e-reader for a month.
Why is it actually
syncing in the background
when I'm trying to use another
application in the foreground?
So these two effects
are very interrelated
and contribute to the overall
user experience of Android.
So the goal of this article
and of these tips and practices
in general is to help
application developers write
better applications, so that we
can make the overall platform
better.
So let's go talk about memory.
Three dynamics to be aware
of is that memory is limited.
And this is far more limited
than you might realize.
Living here with our less
constrained financial resources
and more available technology,
we tend to think of one gig
as being the low end.
You know, there are devices
with two-gig or more
readily available.
So surely, this is what
people have in the real world.
In the real world,
low-end devices
are, A, still being
used, because they
were sold several years ago.
And people don't just
ditch devices for new ones,
unless they're like the
people in this room.
Maybe they don't actually
have enough money
to go buy a new phone whenever
they're excited by it,
so they may keep
that device around
a lot longer than you, the
developer, want them to.
So they're running with
a low memory device,
because they bought
it a while ago.
But the more
insidious dynamic is
that there are still devices
being sold with low memory.
In markets where money or
technology is not as readily
available, they may be
selling these phones
to people that are really
excited about getting
this new device that only
has 512 on it, right?
Not much memory.
It's a new phone.
What are they doing coming out
with that amount of memory?
Well, this is the configuration
that made sense in that market.
And there are a lot of
these phones still being
sold out there.
So even though you are running
a device that you don't consider
high end and you think the
memory problems have gone away,
they actually haven't.
And they're going to be here
for a while because of those two
dynamics.
So it's very important
for you, the developer,
to realize there are these
low memory situations
and to make sure your
application behaves reasonably
well when one of those
situations occurs for the user.
The other issue, as
I alluded to before,
is it that memory is shared.
Everybody is swimming
in the same pool.
I don't really
like that metaphor.
So everybody has to behave, if
you want the overall experience
to be good.
If your application is greedy,
and every other application
is greedy, the entire
experience of the device
will be horrible, because
everybody is constantly
going to be shoving
everybody out of CPU cycles,
as well as memory.
And then, finally, memory
equals performance.
And this is the one I want to
spend a little bit of quality
time on today and explain
what we mean by that.
So first of all, let's
talk about memory.
Let's talk about the
garbage collector
and how it actually
works and why
we see some of the
performance issues that we do.
So there are three
things that cause memory
to be expensive, in terms
of performance, on Android.
One is the allocation,
the process
of actually creating memory
for the new objects that
are being allocated.
The next is concurrent
collection, or just
collection in general,
when we actually
need to clear things out
so that we can make room
for other allocations
that need to happen.
And then the third tends to
be the most painful one, which
is collection-for-allocation.
If anybody's taken
a look at the log
and looked at the GC
information in there,
this is commonly referred
to as GC_FOR_ALLOC.
It's a situation where you
go to allocate something,
there is not a free
space in the heap.
And then the garbage
collector need
to run synchronously, right
then, to free up enough memory
to store your object there.
So let's go into some
of the details there.
We can see the four phases
of normal allocations
and collections.
Here, you have this
new object on the left,
next to the squiggles.
And we need to find
space for that.
Oh, fortunately, there's
a space right there.
We'll pop it in at the top.
This is an unusual
situation where
it was really easy to do that.
So once that's there, then
we enumerate all the objects
to figure out what's still
refer to in the heap.
You can see the red one
doesn't have a reference there.
We mark all of
those, to make sure
that we know what things
are still referred to
and what things can
actually be collected.
And then we collect.
And you see the red
object goes away there,
because there was
no reference to it.
So we can collect that now
and free up space in the heap.
So on Dalvik, there's
actually two pause times
that occur in the
normal process of simply
allocating and collecting.
There's a pause
time to enumerate.
So we basically stop
the world, the GC thread
runs alone in the process.
Everything else is paused,
while it figures out
what the things are in the heap
during the enumeration phase.
And then there's the mark
phase at the end of that.
So it it'll mark all the
things, to figure out what
doesn't have a reference there.
And then it needs to run
one smaller mark phase
at the end of that, in
case there were allocations
while that concurrent
marking was going on.
And there's another pause there.
So there's a large
pause, potentially,
in the enumeration phase.
And then there's a smaller pause
at the end of the mark phase.
And then it can
collect everything.
And it does that concurrently.
In ART, it's a
little bit different.
We eliminated the first pause,
so there's no synchronous pause
during the enumeration phase.
It can do that concurrently.
There is still a small pause
at the end of the mark phase.
It's a little bit
smaller, because there's
been a lot of
optimization work going
into the collector in ART.
So it's better in ART, but
we still have a pause there.
And I should point out,
too, that even when
there's not a
pause here, there's
still stuff happening, right?
So all of this is causing CPU
to do things in the background,
whether it's-- I just turned
on the audio on my screen,
so look out-- even if it
can happen concurrently,
it still means it's
happening, right?
You're still taking up
cycles to do these things.
And in general, it's good
to not spend the cycles,
if you don't have to.
OK, so now, let's talk about
the one that's more problematic.
This is the
GC_FOR_ALLOC situation
where a new object comes in,
and we pop that onto the heap.
And then another one comes
in, and we walk down the heap
and we look for space in
there, and there is no space.
And then we have to actually
run a GC synchronously.
We stop the world.
So we've got a huge
pause in the middle,
while we actually go
and free up the stuff
that we need to in order
to fit this into the heap.
And then we can put it in there
and go on about our business.
And the GC_FOR_ALLOC tends to be
painful both in terms of time--
on Dalvik, this can take 10
to 20 milliseconds, which
is easily more than a frame.
So you're going to
potentially skip
an animation frame in the
middle and cause a hiccup.
And then they're-- I totally
lost my train of thought.
Yeah.
Just gone.
It turns out you
should sleep at night.
So it also means that
none of your other stuff
is running, right?
So it's just going to
pause in the middle.
It's going to do all this
work, and nothing else
can happen at the same time.
So in general, that's a
good thing to try to avoid.
ART makes this a
little bit better.
No, a lot better, because
it has a separate heap
for large objects.
One of the causes of having
to do too many collections
was that all of the objects
were stored together.
So you'd have these little,
tiny temporary objects,
new object, or float,
or integer, or whatever.
And then you'd have this bitmap
taking up a massive amount
of space in the middle.
And it would cause the heap to
get really large-- the amount
of space that would have to
be walked-- to be really big,
and the fragmentation issues
to be much greater in the heap.
And now, ART takes all the
large objects, all the bitmaps--
and they live in a separate
piece of memory over there--
so all the big
ones go out there.
All the little, more temporary
objects go in the main heap.
And it means that there
are far less pauses.
It means also that the
pauses are much smaller.
So whereas, the
previous Dalvik pauses
may have been on the order
of 10 to 20 milliseconds,
now we see pauses of
three to 5 milliseconds,
which is much better.
It's way under the frame
boundary limit, which is great.
But it's still
significant enough
that it can push you over the
frame boundary limit anyway,
so it's still good
thing to avoid.
Meanwhile, while
all this churning
is going on of actually
allocating objects, needing
to collect them to free
up the space for them,
you're also growing your heaps.
So the more allocations
you're asking for,
the more you're causing
the heap to grow over time.
So if you just allocate
more and more objects,
eventually the heap is going
to say, well, I'm out of room.
But you're not up to
your process limit yet,
so I'll grow the heap there.
And so it will go through, A,
the work to do that, and B,
it'll take up more
memory on the device
to allocate that larger heap.
And larger heap means, now,
your task, your process,
is taking up more memory.
There's less available for
the rest of the system.
And you're also
causing your app to be
killed, because you're going
to be taking up more space.
When the task manager is looking
for background apps to kill,
it's going to look
for large ones,
because that's a lot of memory
that it could take back.
An important point to note about
this is that, under Dalvik,
there was no compaction,
which means that when--
this causes big problems with
fragmentation the heap where
you would allocate these
temporary things over time,
and then you would remove
the things that weren't there
anymore.
But the things that were
permanent, or long-lived,
would still be in
the heap somewhere.
And we could never actually
get back that memory.
There is a certain
amount of trimming
that happens under Dalvik
where, if we get rid of enough
of the objects that occupy
an entire page, eventually,
we can hand that
page back to memory.
But in general, you're stuck
in this situation where you
basically grow without bound.
The heap gets larger.
And we can never really
get back all of that space,
even if you only grew it to a
large size very temporarily.
Under ART, this improves,
because we do actually
compact the heap eventually.
When your app goes into
the background, when
it senses that it's an idle time
that it can do this operation,
then it'll take a look
at the heap and realize,
well, there's a lot
objects that went away.
In the meantime, we
can compact the heap.
So it gets better under ART,
but it's still a problem,
especially if you're just
the foreground application.
We're not going to compact
the heap at that time.
All right.
So there's a few points
to come out of this.
So when you have
fewer allocations,
you get a smaller heap.
You also get faster
allocation times,
because there's simply less
work to do to figure out
where the free space is.
You get faster collection
times, because again,
smaller heap, less
things to keep track of.
You get fewer pauses, because
there's less to do over time.
And there's less CPU
usage, because you're not
causing the CPU to
actually continually do
this mark, and sweep, and
collect in the background.
And then, overall, you
get less jank, especially
for the GC_FOR_ALLOC.
If you're constantly
allocating things,
and then you run
into a situation
where there's not enough
free space for a new object,
then you're going to cause
a GC_FOR_ALLOC, which,
in general, will cause jank.
It'll cause you to miss a
frame, particularly on Dalvik,
but also on ART,
because you're basically
causing a whole lot
of work to happen
at a super inconvenient time.
And then, all of this, in
general, I would posit,
leads to happier
users and world peace.
I leave the last item as
an exercise for the reader.
OK, so let's talk about some of
the tips and tricks about using
memory more effectively.
We, meaning me and Romain
Guy gave a talk years
ago at Devoxx-- and
it's up on parleys.com--
that goes over a
lot of details here,
like some of the sizes
and quantities involved.
So I would encourage you
to check out that video.
It has a lot of the details
behind some of these items.
First of all, avoid
allocations when possible.
One of the things
that we've seen--
and there's actually a lint
check for this now-- is
don't allocate in the
middle of your inner loop.
In particular, if you're
in onDraw, and you realize,
well, I need to
draw to this canvas,
and I need a Paint object,
let's get a Paint object.
So we'll create a new Paint
object, and we'll do this.
Incredibly common.
So there's like a lint check
for that specific pattern,
just because so many
people are doing this.
It seems dumb.
You're like, how big can it be?
There's only five letters
in the word, "paint," right?
It turns out it's a problem.
It's a problem for two reasons.
One is not as obvious is
that the Java level object
that we're allocating,
the Paint object,
is kind of the tip
of the iceberg.
We're also allocating stuff
at the native level, which
then needs to be finalized
and collected later,
which is kind of an arduous
process to go through as well.
I'll talk about
finalizers later.
So there's a lot of stuff that's
happening underneath Paint
that you're causing to
happen, just by allocating
a temporary Paint object.
The other one is the churn
that I was talking about.
If you are in onDraw,
and your onDraw
is being called on every
frame of an animation,
and on every frame you're
allocating a Paint object,
well, at some point, that means
that your heap will fill up.
Maybe not in that animation,
but maybe in a future animation,
at some point,
you're going to go
to allocate that Paint object,
and it won't find enough space.
And then, it's going to
have to make the space.
So you're in the
middle of an animation,
you're in your Draw loop, you're
on the UI thread, and GC says,
you know what?
I'm going to have to
collect right now.
Would you please hang on
for a few milliseconds?
And that's what causes
jank for the user.
So don't do that, when
you don't need to.
One of the strategies that we
use internally in the framework
that I would encourage
people to look into,
in specific inner loop
situations like this,
is caching objects.
So one of the tricks--
if you ever look
at the source code
of the framework,
like view.java, or any
of the core classes
there, we will keep around
either instance classes,
or in some limited cases,
static objects, that only get
allocated lazily.
So when we see the
first time that, OK,
we're going to need a
Paint object, or a Rect
object, or a Point object,
for this particular call,
if it's null we'll go
ahead and allocate it then.
And then, thereafter, we'll
just use that shared object.
In a lot of cases.
So in the onDraw
situation, chances are,
you don't need that
Paint object for anything
else in that class.
So you could have an instance
variable-- or a static,
if you want to manage it
that way-- that only gets
used when you're actually
in that onDraw method.
So it seems a little silly.
You might as well
have a local field.
But because of the
memory concerns,
you really want a
cached object instead.
So allocate it lazily,
and then use it
whenever you need to in
that specific method.
You have to be
careful with this.
Obviously, if you're actually
accessing that shared variable,
either instance or static,
from multiple places,
that can get a little tricky.
So it's not a blanket pattern.
Just like all of these
tips, these are not
like hard and fast rules.
But in general, it's
an approach that
can avoid the kind of
expensive, insidiously
expensive, allocations
that we see in inner loops.
Pools-- so object
pools are something
that traditional Java,
certainly server developers,
walked away from years ago.
You know, let the memory manager
manage your objects for you.
You don't need to.
But because of the
allocation concerns
that we have on
Android, sometimes, it's
a good idea to actually do this.
If these are expensive
objects to allocate,
maybe it's better
to actually have
a small pool of these
things and keep them around,
instead of having to reallocate
one every time you need it.
This also can be tricky.
If they're being accessed from
different places in the code,
then there's a bit of management
overhead to go with this.
This is not as easy a thing
as the cached approach
I was talking about, easier.
That's easy.
There's just a single
field to manage.
Object pools, there's
a bit more to it.
There's things like
LRU caches that you
can use to make this easier.
But figure out the right
trade-off for your code.
Arrays-- ArrayList
is pretty good.
I tend to use it a lot.
It's one of the nicer and
more streamlined collections
for storing stuff there.
You keep adding to it.
It'll reallocate when necessary.
But if you just have a
statically determined size
collection that you
need, Array itself
tends to be more optimal
than ArrayList, right?
It doesn't need to
allocate things in there,
it's just got the Array
itself, and then the objects
that you put in it.
So consider using arrays.
They're just a bit more
streamlined and optimal,
and don't do as much churn for
reallocation that collections
would do automatically.
Speaking of collections, I
would encourage you to check out
the Android collections.
So the traditional Java
programming language
collections, they're all
very powerful and useful.
And they're probably
still the right thing
to use for large
collections, like HashMap.
Awesome, if you have a
really large amount of data
that you need to store.
But check out ArrayMap,
instead, if you actually just
have a smaller collection.
It avoids a lot of the boxing,
as well as the allocations that
are inherent in HashMap itself.
So there's a bunch of
collections in Android.
There's ArrayMap.
In the support library,
there's SimpleArrayMap.
Then there's SparseArray.
There's actually a bunch of
sparse things, LongSparse,
LongIntSparse, LongInts, lots
of different combinations.
But they basically use
primitives as keys,
instead of the auto-boxed Java
language versions of those,
like not capital L, Long,
but instead a primitive long.
Wouldn't that be nice?
Methods that mutate-- this is
another pattern that I think
traditional Java programmers
walked away from years
ago, maybe holding their nose.
In general, so let's say
you want to pass in an x,y,
and you want to
get a point return,
because you need that point
data structure to pass into some
other method, right?
So you have this
utility function.
I'm going to pass in x,y.
I'm going to get point back.
Really stupid example.
You could create your
point on your own.
But to illustrate the point--
[LAUGHTER]
Ow.
So traditionally, you
would pass in x, y,
and it would allocate a point.
And it would pass
it back to you.
Not a big deal.
It's just a temporary
object, right?
Again, if you're
in your inner loop,
allocating is, in general, bad.
Wouldn't it be
nice if you didn't
have to reallocate that
thing all the time?
This is just a temporary object.
So instead, what you can
do is keep a cached object
in the caller, and then call a
mutating version of that method
instead.
So instead of passing in
x,y, maybe you pass in x,y
and a point data structure.
And then it fills in
the data structure.
And then that gives
you the option
to allocate it on-the-fly,
if you really want to,
or to keep it and reuse
a cached object instead.
So if you look through
the Android source code,
especially in the
framework, you'll
see a lot of instances of
this internally, where we'll
pass in a Rect that gets filled
in during layouts or whatever.
And this is specifically to
avoid the temporary allocations
that are necessary
to pass back richer
data than simply a single
primitive return value.
And speaking of primitives,
we have primitive types.
We really like them in Android.
In general, if you
use primitive types,
you're going to avoid
all the boxing that's
inherent in using the
object equivalents.
So if you write a method
that takes a capital F Float,
and you're running an animation
or doing a calculation that
has a primitive float,
when you call that method,
it's automatically going to box.
It's going to create a
capital F Float out of it.
There's slightly more overhead
in getting the value of that.
I'm not as concerned about that.
I am concerned about
creating garbage, creating
these small, temporary objects,
when you really didn't need to.
So as much as you can,
stick to the primitives.
The collection classes,
obviously, use the object types
instead, so you can't
really get around it there.
But for all of your
internal methods
that aren't using
collections, there's
no reason to not use
the primitives instead.
They just tend to be
a lot more streamlined
and avoid the memory situations
that we're talking about.
There are a lot language
things that you can trip over,
without really realizing why.
Iterators is one of
my favorite examples.
So I love the for-each syntax.
I don't know why it's called the
for-each syntax, since there's
no "each" in the language.
Somehow, we adopted that
way of referring to it.
And then you go looking for the
primitive, and it's not there.
They should just
maybe call it a for.
So it's very convenient.
It came out in JDK 1.5.
You say, for object
O in this thing.
And then it iterates
through that collection.
Very convenient.
What's going on under
the hood, though-- this
is syntactic sugar.
It is creating an
iterator for you, right?
So it's allocating that object.
And then it's doing
the normal iteration,
using that iterator object.
The iterator approach was
kind of ugly and obtuse.
I don't think people
enjoyed using that.
The for-each works around that.
It makes a nice
streamlined thing,
but it's still doing the
same thing under the hood.
In particular, if your
collection is empty,
it's going to create
an iterator anyway.
It does not know
that it's empty,
until it creates the
iterator and then
tries to get the first item.
And then it says,
oh, your empty.
You need to do this.
So one of the optimizations
that we did along
the way to creating the new
animation system in Honeycomb
was to eliminate all
the allocations that
were going on in every frame.
So we have this new
animation system.
We use this tool internally,
called Allocation Tracker.
I would encourage
everybody to use this,
to make sure that
you're actually
using memory correctly.
So I would start the animation.
I would start
allocation tracking.
I would collect the allocations.
And then the animation
would finish, right?
I don't care if we're allocating
at the beginning and the end.
To some extent, that's
unavoidable, right?
This is Java.
It's a memory garbage
collecting language.
You're going to
allocate objects.
What you don't want to do is
allocate during the animation,
like during the actual frames.
And then I saw that,
on every single frame,
we were allocating
objects for listeners.
What was going on was we had
this View TreeObserver where
you can listen to
various events going on,
layouts, pre-draw,
draw, the things
are happening in
the view hierarchy.
And on every frame,
we would say,
for-ViewTreeObserver, Listener,
whatever, in this collection.
Then we would iterate through,
and we would do something.
In general, nobody
actually added a listener.
It's not typical to
have a listener there.
But we would create an
iterator on every single frame
anyway, because that's
what for-each did for us.
So there's one
specific case where
it doesn't do that, which is,
if it's a primitive array,
it actually does the right
thing and will not create
an iterator for you, so yay.
But otherwise, it's
kind of a good thing
to maybe avoid, if you're
not really sure whether it's
going to create things.
You can certainly go
back to the old approach
of doing an actual
for loop instead,
and just get the
items in the array.
And then, it doesn't
advance to the first one,
if it didn't need it.
Or if you use it, just be
aware of when it's actually
going to cause an allocation
when you don't want it to.
Wait.
Let's go back.
Yeah, this one.
So let's talk about
enums no more.
I'm really tired of this
topic at this conference.
Go to the article and read.
There's nuances to using them.
Please understand the
overhead inherent in enums
and make the right
decision for your code.
Moving on.
Finalizers.
[LAUGHTER]
So one of the things
that's not obvious
about finalizers is nuances
in the language spec
mean that, to
finalize any object,
we actually need
to do a GC twice.
So whenever you have a finalizer
declared on your class,
you're basically forcing
a future GC twice.
And you kind of want to
avoid every single one, so
why are you forcing
two on the system?
There are particular situations
that really require finalizers.
We do use them
internally, specifically,
when we have native objects
that need to be cleared.
So we need to know when
that thing went away,
so that, on the
native side, we can
go ahead and free the native
memory associated with it.
So that's a valid
use case for it.
But I would say, try to limit
the number of valid use cases.
And definitely eliminate
finalizers when you
don't need them in other cases.
They may be convenient,
but there are better ways,
certainly from the
memory standpoint,
to do what you want to do.
Static leaks, this is
one of my favorites.
I may or may not
have caused leaks
in activities in
some of my code.
I should do a deep
dive into the way
that HashMap or
WeakHashMap works.
So there's a situation
where I needed
to store information about
listeners associate with views.
And I said, well, I
know that WeakHashMap
uses a weak reference.
So when that view
goes away-- which
is what I was using
for my key-- then I
know that everything
will be collected.
Turns out that's not true.
The way that WeakHashMap
works, it actually
had a hard reference to the key.
It had a weak reference to
the value, which kind of
turns my head in knots.
But the end result was
that the activity would
undergo a configuration change.
So the phone would rotate,
and it would tear down
the activity, and it would
come up with a new activity.
And all that old
stuff went away,
except that I had a
static WeakHashMap which
had a reference to the
view which implicitly has
a reference to its activity.
Bad thing, in general.
So beware of static
leaks, in general.
The real problem here--
besides my ineptitude
and misunderstanding of
how a WeakHashMap worked
at the time-- was that the
lifetime of the process
is different than the
lifetime of your activity.
This is something I've hit
again and again in Android.
I tend to think of,
when a window comes up,
when basically that
application object
that I'm working with-- which
is, the activity in my mind
is sort of synonymous
with application, that's
the first problem-- when that
comes up, surely, that's where
all my static objects live.
They don't.
They live in the process itself.
And the process is long-lived.
So when you undergo a
configuration change,
we rip down the activity,
and we pop up another one.
And it's in the same process.
So if you have a
static object there--
whether it's a WeakHashMap,
or something else that's
holding on to something it
shouldn't in the old activity--
it will continue
to hold onto it.
So static can be the right
thing to use in some situations,
but is really
dangerous because, just
know that it's going to live
a lot longer than the activity
that you think you're storing
things associated with.
Static initialization
is a good thing
to avoid, in general, especially
for expensive allocations
or expensive operations.
The problem that we
see is that, when
a class gets loaded, and then
does a bunch of static work,
it's going to do all
that stuff right now.
This causes a problem,
for instance, when you
launch your activity, right?
So we're going to go.
We're going to launch.
We're going to try to
launch as fast as possible.
And then it loads this class,
which does a whole lot of work
that it really didn't need to.
Why not do some of
that stuff lazily?
If you didn't actually need
to initialize the database,
whatever, at that
point, why don't you
wait until a better
time, instead of forcing
that to happen immediately?
OK, so third-party code.
We've seen this one a lot,
where again, something
the traditional Java
developers will do
is bring over their libraries
and their approaches
from the old world.
Oh, I really like this
dependency injection library.
So a common one that
we've seen is Guice.
Really powerful.
Very flexible.
People love to use this.
And then they'll
start using that.
It was not written
for mobile, right?
It does a whole
lot of reflection.
And I haven't really talked
about reflection yet.
Big secret,
reflection sucks, OK?
It has a lot overhead associated
with it, a lot of allocations,
as well as just
performance overhead.
So in general, we
tend to avoid it.
Everybody kind of
knows that, right?
You don't really do
reflection, unless you need to.
But a lot of these libraries
that you're dragging in
are doing it on your behalf.
So the general tip here
is to not use a library
or third-party code
in general, unless you
know that it was actually
written for mobile.
Because if it wasn't
written for mobile,
it's probably using
a lot of the patterns
that we're telling you
not to in your code.
So why are you
using it indirectly
in someone else's code?
For dependency
injection, there have
been a couple libraries
written since that
are more tuned to Android.
There was the Dagger library.
And more recently, there's
the Dagger 2 library.
I would suggest you check
those out, if you really
want that functionality.
And in general, just
look for libraries that--
I wish we had a logo
saying, "Mobile-Friendly."
You can look for that logo.
It doesn't exist, but
look for the logo.
Otherwise, just make sure
that you actually know
what that library is doing.
The other problem that we've
seen with third-party code
is, if you're really using
a really large library,
chances are there's a
dependency graph in there where
you're dragging
in a lot of stuff
that you don't necessarily need.
Like, if you are using
library fu, because you really
like that collection class for
managing this particular thing,
and then, all of a sudden
it added 20,000 methods
to your method count and
a whole lot of APK size,
just so that you could
use that one collection,
probably not what you
want in your application.
So just be as concerned
about your library code
as you are about your own code.
So there are mechanisms that
Android provides to help you
with memory concerns.
One of them is trimming memory.
So the system will tell you
when it's getting low on memory.
And you should really
respond to that,
because it's not just telling
you, like, oh, by the way,
I'd really love some memory.
It's not a casual conversation.
It's saying I need memory now.
Could you please free some?
Because otherwise, bad
stuff is going to happen.
So when it goes out, it reaches
out to the activities running
on the system, the
processes, and says,
we're running low on memory.
Can you do something about this?
And there's various
levels of it,
so you can set your warning
and panic appropriately.
But if you're keeping
cached thumbnails around,
just in case the user
wanted to do a fling--
but right now, you're
running in the background,
you don't need those
anymore-- maybe it'd
be a good time to
jettison those.
Because if you can
make yourself smaller,
then maybe the
system can get back
the memory that it needs so that
it doesn't have to go killing
activities, like yours.
So pay attention to
the trim callbacks,
and do something about them.
isLowRamDevice() is
a method on, I think,
Activity Manager that tells
you whether the system--
at the moment, it means
this has 512 memory in it.
So if you really
need more memory
to have the best
user experience,
but you also want to work
adequately on 512-meg devices,
then you might call this
method and set the way
that your application
behaves accordingly.
Avoid large heaps.
There is a way to ask the
system for more memory.
And sometimes,
this is necessary.
You know, you're a
video-playing application where
the videos simply won't
fit into the standard heap,
or you're doing
image manipulation
with massive images,
whatever it is,
there are some corner case
situations for which this
was introduced.
But it also tends to be a back
door for lazy developers who
are like, well, I just--
but I want more memory.
It's easier.
Yes, it is easier.
And it makes a
horrible experience,
because the more you
allocate for your process,
the less everybody else gets.
And then it goes back
to the original point.
So don't use it, unless you
actually really need it.
Please?
Don't keep your
services running.
They can continue to
run in the background.
But if they exist just
for a particular reason,
then finish that purpose, and
then get out of them, right?
Otherwise, they're just
sitting there doing stuff.
If nothing else, they're taking
up memory in the background,
meaning that there's less
available for everybody
else on the system.
And then, finally,
optimize for code size.
So this comes in
in a lot of ways.
But it makes your APK
download better, certainly,
but it also decreases
the amount of stuff
that you're loading into
memory for your system.
So just be smart about how
much memory you're taking up.
So I want to go over
some of the tips
that we have in user interface.
This is sort of a
grab bag of things.
Don't overdraw.
There's a tool on the device
called, Profile Overdraw?
I don't know what it is.
Colt?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHET HAASE: Profile-- what?
AUDIENCE: GPU overdraw.
CHET HAASE: Profile
GPU Overdraw,
so you can see what the
overdraw is on the device.
It paints in a lovely
pallet of pastel colors.
It will indicate to you how
many times each of the pixels
is being drawn on the screen.
The problem is-- so Android uses
a common rendering technique,
called painters fill algorithm--
I guess, because painters used
a lot of rectangles
or something--
where basically, we will paint
all the stuff that you tell us
to in the order
of back to front,
because that's going to
result in the correct display
for the user.
So you've got a
window background?
Great.
We'll paint the
window background.
You have a container
covering the window?
Great.
We'll paint the container
with it's opaque background.
Oh, you have another
container covering that?
That's great.
We'll paint that one too.
You have a list view,
which has background?
We're going to paint
the background.
Oh, all of your items
have background--
and all of a sudden, when you
finally get to, like, the text
in a list view, you've
painted each of the pencils
in those characters
five or six times.
That's something that the GPU
doesn't really like to do,
right?
That was a lot of
wasted effort in there.
So what you really
need to do is actually
figure out what opaque
objects are completely
covering what other opaque
objects and maybe eliminate
some of that overhead there.
So you've got the
window background?
Great.
Use it.
Set it to the background color
that you want, and then don't
have an opaque background
on the containers that
are sitting on top of it.
So take a look at your
nested hierarchy there.
See what the organization
is of containers, as well
as the opacity of the
backgrounds that they're using.
And then, do the
right thing there,
to make sure that we're drawing
as few times as possible
on every pixel.
So use the tool.
See what your overdraw is like.
Red is bad.
I'll give you a little
tip, red is bad.
And then, do something about it.
Avoiding null window
backgrounds-- so one
of the tricks to avoid overdraw
ends up in some artifacts
that you should be aware of.
So people will eliminate
the window background,
because they're
like, great, then
I don't have the overdraw
of painting the window,
and then also painting the
first container on top of it.
It'll just paint the container.
That's true.
On the other hand,
sometimes then,
you have an artifact
where all we have to paint
is the window itself.
So like we're animating
in the keyboard,
the IME is animating in.
And the Window Manager is going
to handle painting the window.
Or when we're launching
the window itself,
the activity is not
running yet, we're
going to be animating
in the starting window,
and it's empty.
There's null.
The Window Manager
has nothing to paint.
You're going to end up with
an artifact on the screen.
Either it's going to draw
black, or on some GPUs,
it may draw garbage
on the screen
because there's undefined
contents in that buffer.
So the window background
is there for a reason.
It's there to tell the
Window Manager what
to paint on the screen, when
it has no other information
about the activity.
So keep the window background.
But to avoid the
overdraw issues,
see how you can use
that window background
to do the right thing,
instead of then having
an opaque background
on the container that
overlays the window.
Also, avoiding disabling
the starting window--
this is another situation
that results in some artifacts
where people will disable
the starting window,
because they didn't want
that blank window up
before their activity launch.
But again, the Window Manager
doesn't know what to paint,
if we don't have
a starting window.
I would say, instead, actually
use the starting window
more effectively.
You can brand your
application with this.
We've seen particularly
ineffective approaches
where someone wants a
splash screen before they
get into their activity.
Maybe that game took a couple
seconds to launch or whatever,
so they're like, OK, well,
have a splash screen experience
here.
But then they get
this weird experience
where Windows Manager
doesn't know what to paint,
so it doesn't do
anything for a while,
because there's no
starting window.
And then a splash screen
starts after a second or so
with this completely
different experience.
And then the game starts with
a completely different look.
Pretty awful.
Or in some situations
it gets even worse
where they kept the
starting window,
because they didn't actually
understand what it was.
They have a starting
window, and then they
have a splash screen
that's completely separate,
and then they have
the game screen.
So then you have three
completely different
experiences over
time, which is nice,
if you want different
experiences, but kind of sucks.
What they should
actually do instead
is remove their splash
screen, and take their logo,
take their branding
situation, and use
that as a background on the
starting window instead.
Then, they get the benefit of
having the starting window,
so that the system knows what
to do before the activity is
actually up and
running, and then
they also get to
brand that as well
and have the splash
screen experience
before their application starts.
There's some tips about
avoiding UI stalls.
So the UI thread really
likes to run and keep
running, otherwise,
the user's going
to sit there looking at a frame
while it's actually busy doing
something that it shouldn't be.
So inflation tends
to be expensive,
so try not to inflate
when you don't have, to
or try to minimize the amount
of inflation happening.
If you have a really
complex view hierarchy,
maybe you didn't need
all of that all the time.
Maybe you could actually
use view stubs in there
and inflate other stuff
on-the-fly as necessary,
instead of having like, I don't
know, Play Store-like hierarchy
that gets inflated
on-the-fly whenever
you launch your activity.
That would be nice.
Now, handling events.
When you get an
event, it's nice to do
less expensive operations.
It's nice, when someone
clicks a button,
if you don't actually make
a network call, in general,
or go to the database.
You kind of want to do
that stuff asynchronously,
off the UI thread, because
those events are being processed
in the same thread that's
handling your animation
events, your input events,
as well as your rendering
events and layout.
All of that stuff has to
happen on the UI thread.
So anything that
you're doing that's not
visual, that's not UI-related
should really happen elsewhere.
Even if it will
end up in data that
does populate the UI,
which a lot of this
does-- like they
click on the button,
that means some
transaction where
we need to re-populate the data
that the user is looking at.
That's great, but you don't have
to do it synchronously, right?
So you could spawn an
asynchronous task, AsyncTask,
or loader, or whatever,
to go get that data.
And then, when it's back,
then you can populate the UI.
In the meantime, the
user was actually
able to interact with
your application,
and it didn't seem so janky.
Measuring and layout
is quite expensive.
It's good to avoid it,
particularly during animations.
So if you wanted to, let's
say, animate an object
to move from one
location to another,
you could actually animate
the layout params, right?
You could change
the layout params
that were causing that thing
to be positioned in the window.
You could.
And that's kind of the
physically correct thing to do.
Well, change the layout params.
That forces a re-layout.
And then, it'll figure out
where it's supposed to be.
And then, it'll draw it
at the correct place.
And in the meantime, it's going
to run a lot slower than you
wanted it to.
You're going to miss
frames in there,
depending on the complexity
of your hierarchy.
It's a lot better
to actually animate
with post-layout values, like
translation x translation y.
Don't change the layout
params, which force a layout.
Instead, animate something
that makes it visually correct,
and then fix up the
layout at the end.
Or a typical technique
that we use in animations
is figure out where
it's going to be
at the end of the animation.
So it'll run layout,
it'll figure out
where it needs to be.
And then, you've set an
onPreDrawListener on it.
And then, in your on
onPreDrawListener,
you say, OK, well, I know I want
to animate to this other spot
down there.
So I'm going to run an
animation, basically
rewind to where it was
before, and then run forward
to the new layout location.
So basically, running
translation y from negative 100
to zero.
This is essentially the
approach that we used
in the transitions package.
We put an onPreDrawListener.
We figure out where it was.
We figure out where it's going.
And then we set up the
animation to rewind and then
play forward.
Drawing-- in general, that's
related to the allocation
concerns and the amount of
operations you're actually
doing in the onDraw and then the
animation concerns, in general.
Just be aware that, when you're
in the middle of an animation,
every expensive
operation you're doing,
or every memory allocation
could be contributing
to missing a frame.
It may not seem like
that big a deal.
Like 30 frames a
second, 60 frames
a second, it's still
moving on the screen.
The real problem comes in
when it's inconsistent.
So if you're typically able
to get 60 frames a second,
but eventually a GC kicks in
because you were allocating
a bunch of stuff in
onDraw or whatever,
then there will be a
skipped frame in the middle.
So yeah, 30 frames a second
is reasonably smooth,
if it was consistent.
But going from 60 down
to 30 and then back to 60
causes a hiccup that's very
noticeable to the user.
In the middle, it's going to
pause just slightly and then
skip forward longer than
it would have if it had
a smooth frame rate instead.
Avoid complex view hierarchies--
I alluded to this before.
Like don't have more
views than you need.
Don't have deeper nested
layouts than you need.
I pull out some applications
in Hierarchy Viewer--
who's used Hierarchy Viewer?
OK, good.
Getting there.
We're getting there.
We'd like 100% someday.
It's a really good way to
get a mental model of what
your application looks
like on the inside, what
the model and the container
hierarchy is like.
I've seen some
applications that have
this long tail of
containers where they've
got a relative layout,
and then there's
a linear layer inside
of that, and then
there's a frame layout.
Each one of these
things, it had a purpose.
Somebody had a reason for that.
Like, I want to have
this background here.
And then there's
this other layout
that's tuned to have the right
fringe effect on-- I don't
know what their reasoning was.
I'm sure there was a good
one, but not good enough.
What you want to
do is figure out
how to have the single
container that needed,
instead of the long
nested thing that's simply
going to cause more
overhead for inflation,
for layouts traversal, for
rendering, all of this stuff.
Every layer in a
hierarchy is just
causing more work for
the framework every time
we need to redraw you.
Also, relative
layout is probably
the most flexible layout.
It allows you to do the
association with sibling views,
and the stuff on
the side, and I want
to align this next to that.
So it's the most flexible,
which is why, unfortunately, it
is the layout that
we use when you
create a new project
in Android Studio.
This is not something I'm
real happy about right now.
We would like to
change this eventually.
The problem is that
relative layout causes
us to measure twice, right?
So if you are associating
views with other views,
that means we're going to ask
all the views how big they
want to be and where
they want to be.
Well, we're going to ask
how big they want to be,
because we need to figure
out where to put them.
So we're going to
ask all of them,
and we're going to take
all this information
and we'll crunch
on it a little bit.
And we'll say, OK, we know
how big everyone wants to be.
Now, we have more
information about all
the relative locations
and sizes of things,
we're going to ask
you one more time.
So it's going to measure twice
before it actually lays out.
So if you have a relative
layout at the top,
basically, you're measuring
every view in the hierarchy
twice.
Or even worse, what we've seen
is nested relative layouts.
And then you basically
double it for every layer
in the hierarchy.
So a relative layout sitting
beneath another relative
layout, you're measuring
all the children
of that nested one four times.
Probably a bad idea.
So if you don't need
a relative layout--
we understand that,
in some situations,
you need it, usually not at the
top level of your hierarchy.
It's usually needed
at a container level
where you actually need the
association of the siblings
or whatever.
So go ahead and use it
when you need it, but be
aware of the overhead of it.
And try not to put it
at a really high level.
And certainly try
not to nest it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
CHET HAASE: Is it better
to have a relative layout
with a lot of views?
Or a nested linear layout?
It probably depends on-- so the
answer is, always, it depends.
It depends on how high up
in the hierarchy it is.
So if it's sitting
at the top, then it's
going to cause all
of that overhead
to everything sitting
underneath it.
If it's at the bottom
of your hierarchy,
it's not going to
cause that much, right?
You're going to be
measuring all the views,
but you wanted to
do that anyway.
Like you wanted those
sibling associations.
That's probably fine.
Nested linear layout
also has its own overhead
associated with it.
So it doesn't measure
twice, but you just
added a bunch of
layers in there.
It's also worth
considering custom layouts
at some point too.
If you find yourself
tying yourself in knots
and adding more and more
nested linear layouts
to get the particular
effect you wanted
with all right padding
and associations
between all the different
subviews and sub containment
hierarchies, at some
point, it's much more
optimal to simply
create a custom layout.
So you subclass ViewGroup, or
you subclass some layout that
does most of what you want.
And then you do your own
measure in the layout.
And that'll probably save
you time in the long run.
Launch fast-- go ahead
and try to get the UI up
as quickly as possible.
This pertains to
some of the stuff
I was talking about
before, like not doing
too much in static
initializers, like not inflating
all of the views that you might
possibly need in the future.
Instead, just get up and
face the user with something
quickly.
Otherwise, they
click the button,
they've seen the
starting window,
and then four seconds later,
they see your application.
Horrible experience, right?
Wouldn't it be
better to be faced
with a simple UI that
could then populate
itself later as necessary?
Defer the extra work.
If you didn't need those
fields initialized,
maybe you could actually
initialize them lazily instead.
And also, measure cold starts.
So when your
application starts, it's
important to understand the
different dynamics of what
state it was starting from.
So when it started from the
first time after a reboot,
that's what we refer
to as a cold start.
This means it's all
the work that we
had to do to actually
read in the APK,
to load all the classes, to
initialize all the stuff,
and then to do the first layout
and rendering of that thing.
There's the window animation,
but let the Window Manager deal
with that.
It's all the stuff
they were doing inside
of your application, to simply
get to the first frame that
is displayed.
So it's important to understand
how much time that takes
and to measure it appropriately.
So if you launch
your application,
and then you hit
the Home button,
and then you launch it
again, your application,
depending on the amount of
memory available on the system,
was probably still
resident in memory.
So all we really needed to
do was display it again.
We re-rendered it.
Period.
Right?
We didn't reload it.
In a lot of cases, we didn't
need to do another layout.
We're basically just showing the
same thing that we had before.
So you're like, this is great.
I can start in 50 milliseconds.
I'm super fast.
And then the next time you
reboot, it takes four seconds.
So what you want to do to really
get a better measurement is
actually kill the task, right?
So go into Recents and
swipe it out of the way.
And that'll get you most of
the way toward the situation
of a cold start from reboot.
So get it out of memory.
Make sure that we're actually
dragging in all of the stuff
again, to really understand how
much time your application is
taking to launch.
I want to talk about
some of the tools that
are important to use.
Hopefully, everybody
uses most of these.
Systrace, I talked about
a little bit yesterday.
Colt talked about it as well.
Super powerful tool.
Super confusing.
There's so much
information in there.
There's so many options.
You look at it, and you're
like, I see a lot of green.
I see a lot of red.
I don't know what
to do about it.
We added to the tips, the little
circular bubbles in the middle.
I would encourage you to
get the latest Systrace
and play with that.
Click on the tips and see
what it's trying to tell you.
In general, the
problems that we've
seen that we can do
some amount of analysis
on in the tool now for you
tend to be common issues,
like you're in the middle of an
animation, and you ran layout,
or you're not reusing
the view when getView
is called on your list view.
So some simple things
that we noticed over,
and over, and over again that
we now fed into the tool,
so you can get for free.
And then, once you start
using Systrace more,
you start to understand,
OK, well, these
are the VSYNC pulses.
This is the amount of CPU usage
that was going on at the time.
My thread is
sleeping, because it's
tied to this other
event in surfaceflinger,
which was processing the GL.
There's a lot of
associations that you
can get over time and
practice with using the tool.
But it's really the
only tool that we
have that gives you the big
picture of what was actually
going on in the device that was
causing the jank that you see.
And you can see the jank
in the output there.
You can see, I've
got regular pulses.
I'm doing my
performTraversals, which
is the rendering loop in the UI
thread, on every single frame.
And then I skip three frames.
Why?
That's what you
need to figure out,
so that you can fix the
jank in your application.
Allocation tracker, super
useful for all of the memory
stuff that I was
talking about before.
So obviously, we're
using a VM here,
runtime that's going to
be allocating objects.
You can't avoid allocations.
What you should
try to do is avoid
allocating during times when
you know it could cause jank
for the user.
So run that animation,
and then see
what's being allocated
during the animation.
And make sure that
all of the objects
are not actually come
in from your code.
Ideally, there would
be no allocations
during the animation.
But if you can't fix
that, you can at least
fix the ones that are
coming from your code that
don't actually need to
happen during the animation.
Traceview, there's
two versions of it.
There's a sampling, as well as
non-sampling-- instrumented?
What's the other way
they refer to it?
What do you-- sampling
means, OK, it's
going to look occasionally
and see where it's at.
This has very low
overhead, which
means you're going to
get reasonable times back
for how long these
various things are taking.
But it's not going to
give you the full call
stack for where the code
was at any point in time.
So you want to use the
instrumented version, instead,
if you're trying to
understand the code
flow in how you actually got to
this at that particular time.
However, that has a fair amount
of overhead associated with it
just in each of
the method calls,
so make sure that you're not
optimizing the wrong thing.
Don't look at the
raw, absolute times
you're getting out of
Traceview, if you're
using the instrumented version,
because the times that it's
reporting for method
calls is really
out of whack with reality.
I have optimized stuff before
and saved zero time in the end
result, just because it
wasn't really giving me
the right information.
So it's useful for
understanding the flow
and for relative times,
but don't take the numbers
to seriously if you're using
the instrumented version.
Hierarchy Viewer, we
talked about that.
MAT, I would also call out
the new Memory Analysis
Tool in Android Studio.
Memory Monitor--
I think-- there's
a couple of new memory tools.
One of them is Memory
Monitor that just shows you
the use of memory over time.
The other one actually
analyzes leaks and dependencies
in the graph.
So check that one out.
Should be a lot easier
to use and more tuned
for Android dynamics than
MAT, which is an Eclipse tool.
So basically, to use MAT,
you take a heap dump,
and then you go into
MAT and you basically
see what objects are still
alive that you didn't expect.
So this is where you find out
things like activity leaks.
But as I said, there's
possibly an easier tool
to use in Android
Studio for that.
There's also an external tool
put out by the folks at Square,
called LeakCanary, that I would
suggest you check out as well.
Memory Monitor, I just mentioned
that, for Android Studio.
And then there's
on-device tools.
So those were tools that
you run on the host,
on your desktop machine.
But then there's
device tools where
you can see, in real time,
some of the information
that you need to
tune performance.
There's Strict mode.
You can enable
that, and it'll do
a red flash whenever your
code is doing something
that it shouldn't
on the UI thread,
like making a network access,
or disc access, or whatever.
GPU profiling,
there's the overdraw
set that we talked about.
There's also the
raw performance.
It'll put colored
bars on the screen
to show you how much
time you're taking
in each of the various
phases of rendering.
So it'll show you
whether there's
a spike at a particular
time, because you're
getting inconsistent
results from this thing,
or whether you're just
consistently taking
too much time creating
all the rendering objects,
or whatever it is.
Duration scale, this is useful
if you want to just slow down
your animations so you
can see what's actually
going on on the screen.
I actually find Screen Record
to be a much more useful tool
for debugging animations,
because I really
wanted to see it
run in real time,
it's just that my eyes
don't work that fast.
So I'll do a Screen
Record, and then
upload the MP4 from the device.
And then I can frame step it
in some animation tool, or just
a movie player.
And then I can see what
happened on every single frame
to try to track the artifacts
or the problems there.
Then Hardware
Layer Updates, this
is another visual tool on
the device that shows you
when you're updating
information that is currently
cached in a layer, which
is generally a no-no.
I would say that
there's time for Q&A,
except for the fact that the
timer is running out right now.
So thanks, for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]